hola hoy vamos a aprender a usar khan
academy como una herramienta útil para
los maestros para fortalecer los
aprendizajes de nuestros estudiantes lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es ir a
google.com y en la barra que está en la
parte superior vamos a escribir khan
academy así como lo estoy escribiendo
can acá en
el primer link que debe salir es este
que es en ese punto
khan academy punto org es importante que
entremos a la página que dice ese punto
khan academy porque es la versión en
español si entramos a la que dice
directamente khan academy nos vamos a ir
a la versión de inglés así que tenemos
que ir a esta versión aquí hacemos clic
y vamos a ir a la página de canacar esta
es la página
aquí lo vamos a ver que khan academy
tiene diversos cursos sistemas como
matemáticas ciencia economía
computación más abajo en la parte
inferior vamos a poder conocer más
acerca de la organización del impacto y
del equipo que está detrás de esta
plataforma educativa
hoy lo que vamos a hacer es nos vamos a
crear una cuenta como maestros para
empezar a usar khan academy con los
estudiantes lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es ir aquí en la esquina superior
derecha donde dice regístrate y hacemos
clic aquí en regístrate y nos va a salir
una página como ésta
tenemos que para crearnos una cuenta
como profesor le hacemos clic donde dice
profesor
aquí
y aquí nos da tres opciones uno es
entrar con una cuenta de google si ya la
tuviéramos iniciar esta cuenta con
nuestra cuenta de facebook o
registrarnos con un correo electrónico
en este caso lo vamos hacer con un
correo electrónico que puede ser
cualquier correo electrónico
de gmail yahoo hotmail el del colegio o
la universidad
cualquiera que sea con cualquiera se
puede crear una cuando se le hacemos
clic aquí en el botón y nos va a pedir
que pongamos nuestro correo electrónico
en este caso yo voy a poner el correo
electrónico contacto perú
arroba
khan academy
punto org que es mi contacto
voy a poner el nombre pueden poner
juan por ejemplo y de apellido pérez en
este caso yo voy a poner contacto perú
y tienen que crear una contraseña de por
lo menos 8 caracteres que tenga por una
combinación de letras números y otros
caracteres
entonces que voy a poner
una contraseña
y cuando haya puesto mi contraseña en mi
correo electrónico y el nombre y
apellido
solo tengo que darle click donde dice
regístrate en la parte inferior es
importante que recordemos este correo
electrónico y esta contraseña porque va
a ser nuestra cuenta para usar khan
academy siempre entonces tal vez podemos
apuntarlo en algún lugar o usarla
el mismo mail y contraseña que usamos en
nuestro mail personal depende de lo que
cada uno de nosotros quisiéramos hasta
cuando estamos seguros de tener la
información correcta le damos clic a
regístrate
y en este momento me sabe de que estamos
iniciando una sesión
entonces lo primero que me academia es
la bienvenida como maestro dice que
estamos encantados de que te hayas
individual a los más de un millón de
profesores que santana académico
y me va a dar como un primer tour para
conocer un poco la plataforma nos vamos
a darle click vamos a empezar a que lo
primero me pregunta es qué materias o
cursos estás usando como maestro
entonces imaginemos que yo soy un
maestro de matemáticas le voy a dar clic
al ver enseño aritmética
y voy a poner que enseño por ejemplo el
mundo de las matemáticas que es donde
aparecen todos los cursos de matemáticas
cuando estoy seguro de los cursos pongo
continuar
y aquí la plataforma me sugiere hacer un
recorrido de 4 minutos de la clase de
muestra aritmética donde aprenderemos
ejercicios de práctica a crear tareas y
reportes de tareas no acá yo puedo
hacerle clic a este botón azul para ir
de este tour o empezar directamente con
una clase real en esta oportunidad
sugiero que por primera vez hagamos el
tour lo podemos hacer juntos entonces
voy a hacer clic acá en la casilla azul
lo primero que me explica la plataforma
si ven aquí es la parte en la parte
inferior izquierda este es en la parte 1
de 3 nos va a contar un poco de los
ejercicios estoy acá te dice vista
previa de este ejercicio entonces de lo
que experimentan tus estudiantes cuando
responden una pregunta no también
echaremos un vistazo al banco completo
de pruebe entonces la plataforma te
invita a probar un ejercicio antes de
comenzar vamos a darle clic se responde
una pregunta puedes utilizar nuestras
pistas para obtener ayudas si tu
respuesta es incorrecta inténtalo de
nuevo o usa las pistas para elegir para
llegar a una solución paso a paso vamos
a animarnos aquí y hacer como si
fuéramos estudiantes y vamos a darle
clic a responde una pregunta
en este caso lo que vemos es un
ejercicio de siete problemas en la parte
inferior y el primer ejercicio nos
aparece cuáles son más son iguales a 20
quintos
y nos dice que elijamos alguna de las
respuestas estoy yo en este caso a ver
vamos a ver
en el primero
a ver vamos a ver la primera opción a
ver si es la correcta y evidentemente me
dice que sí
buen trabajo me felicita por haber
respondido correctamente
y aquí el mismo tour de la plataforma me
dice si quiero echar un vistazo al banco
de preguntas cada ves que tus
estudiantes practiquen este ejercicio
verá un nuevo conjunto de preguntas de
este banco de preguntas más grandes
podemos revisar este banco de preguntas
y aquí vemos por ejemplo que en
descompone fracciones los estudiantes
harán 7 ejercicios de estas 24 preguntas
sentiremos que hay 24 preguntas cada una
de diferente nivel de dificultad pero
sobre el tema de descomposición de
fracciones
esto es muy interesante para poder
conocer más o menos más a fondo cómo es
la plataforma antes de comenzar a usarlo
con los estudiantes
des a cádiz en la primera parte de tu
recorrido está completa en la parte
inferior izquierda ahora qué hace para
este ejercicio vamos a asignar los
estudiantes de muestra
entonces acá podemos poner continua para
crear tareas
y aquí lo que nos estaba mostrando el
tour es que es muy fácil asignar tareas
y lo vamos a ver también hoy día vamos a
asignar este ejercicio a tus alumnos de
muestra y luego revisaremos sus informes
para ver dónde los estudiantes de
nuestra tuvieron dificultades acá nos
invitó a hacerle clic a asignar
y lo que nos sale cuando damos click lo
que nos sale cuando damos click a
asignar es este cuadro que nos dice
asignar un elemento que es el que
habíamos elegido y nos dice no si
queremos
agregar un conjunto diferente de
preguntas para cada estudiante o si
vamos a agregar el mismo conjunto de
preguntas para todos ustedes esto que
quiere decir que del banco de preguntas
que vimos por ejemplo de las 24 de los
24 ejercicios que habían se chocolate
and se elige en 7 para todos los
estudiantes de la misma forma o de este
banco de preguntas se eligen diferentes
tipos de preguntas para cada uno esto
depende de cada maestro yo en este caso
voy a elegir de cada que los estudiantes
les lleguen diferentes preguntas
entonces voy a elegir el primer botón si
quisiera el segundo simplemente la ok
liga pero voy a elegir el primero
entonces luego aquí me dice que asignó
estos ejercicios de este grupo de
ejercicios a la clase de muestra no
porque todavía no he creado ninguna
clase
a todos los estudiantes de la clase
y le toca poner una fecha límite
entonces le vamos a poner que la fecha
el límite es para les voy a dar una
semana
hoy estamos 8 de diciembre para el 16 de
diciembre hasta el final del día y le
asignó
y en este mes estos estudiantes de
muestra están trabajando algunos están
haciendo una segunda serie de preguntas
para tratar de mejorar su puntuación y
ahora y terminar es una simulación de lo
que eligen los estudiantes a ellos les
llegaría una invitación diciéndoles que
su profesor les ha dejado una tarea
ahora vamos a revisar el reporte de
tareas de 2000 alumnos
en este momento me dice que para ver la
pestaña de tareas haga clic aquí y voy a
la pestaña de tareas
lo primero que me sugiere es que vea el
reporte desde echó un vistazo a las
preguntas de la tarea con las que estos
estudiantes tuvieron más problemas
entonces le hago clic a cada vez reporte
y lo que vemos en esta página de reporte
es primero la pregunta que más
contestaron marlins estudiantes 14 de 8
estudiantes que respondieron a esta
pregunta lo hicieron incorrectamente
aquí puedo ver cuáles estudiantes no
pudieron resolver este problema
y aquí me sale bueno una lista
imaginaria de estudiantes quienes lo
respondieron incorrectamente quienes
correctamente y cuántos intentos les
tomo para responderlo no correctamente
en este caso por ejemplo sabemos que el
primer alumno y manny coleman
no respondió correctamente y lo intentó
tres veces no entonces hasta aquí ya yo
como maestro sé que estudiantes
necesitan volver a repasar el tema en
este caso de descomposición de
fracciones y quienes ya están listos
para pasar a la siguiente etapa
si vemos aquí además dice veamos como en
la esquina inferior izquierda dice cómo
les fue a los estudiantes en todas sus
tareas podemos volver a la pestaña de
tareas le hacemos clic
y se ve el desempeño de cada estudiante
en la tarea ver calificaciones del
estudiante y lo que me aparece es la
lista de todos los estudiantes con el
mayor puntaje obtenido por cada uno de
ellos si bien están coloreados no
quienes estuvieron 100% tiene un color
verde
en la parte inferior quienes tuvieron un
resultado intermedio como 86 puntos
sobre 100 están en amarillo y quienes
esto ya tienen que mejorar están en un
rojo
así es como el maestro puede ver el
progreso de cada unos estudiantes en la
pestaña de tareas aquí lo que nos dice
el tour en la esquina inferior izquierda
es que así termina el recorrido para
conocer un poco más de la plataforma y
comenzar a usarlo
entonces que hacemos clic a terminar el
recorrido y me da las felicitaciones
porque nuestro recorrido está completo y
estamos listos para comenzar con nuestra
clase real
ahora nosotros lo que hemos hecho
al inicio fue crearnos una cuenta con
nuestro correo y nuestra contraseña
hacer el tour de recorrido inicial y
ahora estamos listos para comenzar a
usar canales
antes de comenzar a usarlo como maestros
yo les voy a sugerir que vayan a la
esquina superior derecha donde está su
nombre en este caso yo le puse en
contacto a perú
y vayan a la parte donde dice
configuración
porque en esta sección ustedes pueden
configurar su cuenta si bien en la
primera parte por ejemplo se equivocaron
a la hora de poner su nombre simplemente
pueden aquí cambiar el nombre real
pueden poner el género si quisieran su
fecha de nacimiento la lengua principal
en la que va a aparecer la plataforma
aquí también pueden cambiar su
contraseña si quisiera
pueden vincular su cuenta de khan
academy a otras redes sociales como
facebook no pueden poner su teléfono
celular y aquí es muy importante en la
parte de roles esté marcado
principalmente la de maestro porque esto
lo que nos permitirá ver muchas
herramientas que tienen khan academy
para los maestros si ven también está
marcada la del estudiante porque la idea
es que el maestro también puede fungir
de estudiante en su práctica y así puede
ir viendo cómo se estudiantes van a ver
las tareas esto lo vamos a ver en un
siguiente vídeo además es importante que
en la página de inicio se la del panel
del tutor no no la del estudiante en el
panel de padres sino la del todo
si por ave hubieran puesto algo
diferente aquí lo pueden cambiar y
guardan cambios y si en algún momento
bueno quisieran eliminar su cuenta y
crear otra nueva
es aquí donde le dan eliminar la cuenta
bueno con eso ya tenemos nuestra cuenta
creada y estamos listos para usar khan
academy para volver a la página
principal siempre le damos clic en la
parte superior derecha donde dice khan
academy hasta el logo
y van a poder volver a la página
principal de caracas